I'm sorry.
You
get all
I was
reading like
Okay, folks. Um, couple of things. One
is if you get a chance, get on
Brightpace and make sure your grade
scores match up to what you have on your
quizzes. You know, just, you know, might
as well get those lined up. I also sent
that grade checker sheet. Don't take it
too literally. I mean, in a sense,
you're going to enter your numbers.
You're going to see what you can get.
So, but I wanted to kind of, you know,
make it as transparent as possible in
terms of you seeing what your total
score will be.
Final reminder, of course, your project
is due a week and a half from today. So,
expect me to nag you consistently for
the next 10 days, 11 days. No, because
the end is near, right? So, with all
those in place, let's talk a little bit
more about dividends. Now, we were
talking about good reasons to pay
dividends. And one of those reasons is
that if you acquire investors who like
dividends, a dividend
clientele, then you should continue to
pay dividends. you get locked in and
sometimes that can create a problem
because you get locked in and then your
business changes. You're not sure what
to do. Today I want to talk about a
second reason why companies might
initiate dividends and increase
dividends. This is from a very old
study. It's about four, it's almost 30
years old, but it's been updated since.
And I'll talk a little bit about what's
changed. And what this study looked at
very simply is what happens to the stock
price of a company when a company
announces a dividend change. Remember
this is not at the X dividend date. This
happens three weeks ahead. The board of
directors gets together and says we're
going to increase dividends or we're
going to cut dividends. It just looks at
the stock price effect. So when
companies announce a dividend change,
the stock price jumps, but don't get too
excited. Jumps about
1%. On average. So dividend increases
are on average good news. Dividend
decreases on average are bad news. And I
want somebody to explain a disconnect
here. When dividends go up, the stock
price goes up about 1%. When dividends
go down, stock prices go down about
5%. So why is a dividend increase less
good news than a dividend decrease is
bad news?
Anybody want to give that a shot? Why is
the dividend cuts you know in terms of
news effect greater? Yes.
In fact, if you remember that graph of
dividend changes, dividend increases
outnumber dividend decreases 4:1 to 5:1.
So when it happens, people say things
must be really bad for you to cut
dividends. That was the original study.
And for a long time, this was the story
that was told. Dividends are good
signals because and you're saying what
am I signaling? Remember when you
increase dividends you effectively have
to have earnings to cover the dividend.
So people say when you increase
dividends that must fe mean that you
feel more secure about future earnings.
Nice story right? But can you think of a
different story where in fact a dividend
increase can be bad news for a
company company invested. If Nvidia
announces a big increase in dividends,
good news or bad news,
anybody? What do you think? Could be bad
news because that means that they're not
going to grow that as much as they
thought they In other words, you invest
in a great growth. Palunteer announces a
big dividend. I'm terrified if I'm a
Palunteer investor, right? Because you
think this company has great investment
prospects, all these amazing things it
can do, and it says, "No, we're going to
pay a big dividend." said they must know
their you can see already the kind of
stories you have to tell for signaling
requires you to kind of build these
these stories built on fact you know
initially some facts but then you're
building a story on top of it. So the
bottom line is for the most part
dividend increases are good
news but sometimes when a company
initiates dividends it might actually be
bad news. This is actually from a study
that looked at earnings
growth before and after dividends are
initiated. So these are the years before
year four years before 3 years before
two years before one year before. Year
of the dividend initiation is peak
growth and then after the dividends
initiated you actually see growth drop
off. So dividends can be good news, they
can be bad news. But here's I think the
most interesting statistic. That study I
told you happened way back in time, you
know, 30 years ago. It's been updated
since. And here's the bottom line from
all of these studies. The effects of
dividend changes have become more muted
over time as you go from the 1960s
through this
century. Why might that be? Why are
dividends conveying less news today than
they did 30 or 40 years
ago? Where do we get our news now?
30 years ago used to open up the Wall
Street Journal and if you were lucky the
company got covered you know it was a
big company small company there wasn't
much
information it wasn't easy to access
equity research reports there was no
Yahoo Finance online there's basically
you your information sources were much
more limited so when a company announced
a change in dividends it carried much
more news effect I mean it's for the
same reason where do you get breaking
news now whether it's in sports or in
politics. Where do you get your breaking
news
now? I get it on
Twitter. I often hear about something
nine time know five times out of 10 it's
fake news but you still get news mixed
in with fake news. And I think
increasingly as our access to
information increases the effects of
companies increasing dividends to convey
news is becoming less effective.
So, if you're a company and you say and
you come to me and say, "Look, I want
increased dividends to send news to the
market, my advice is, hey, go on
Twitter, put out a tweet. The news will
probably get out. Why put yourself in
this $3 a year dividend just to convey
the news? It's having much less effect.
So, dividends send a signal. I'm not
sure it's good news or bad news, but
clearly markets read into it."
There's another reason you might pay
dividends. And as I said, it's not a
noble reason. Remember this graph I
showed you? What happens when dividends
go up? Stock prices jump, right?
Investors are for on at least on average
happy. On that same day, if you look at
the corporate bonds issued by the same
company and you look at the returns that
happen. So basically, I know it's a
tough graph to read, but if the the
graph drifts up, the stock's doing well
or the investment is doing well. If it
drifts down, it's doing badly. So stocks
and average drift up. But if you look at
what happens to bonds in the same
company, they're drifting
down. Why? If you're a bond holder in a
company, are you affected by the company
paying
dividends? Kelly, you want to try? What?
If you're a bond holder in a company,
why might a company paying dividends
affect you as a bond holder?
You'd prefer sit as cash in a company,
right? because they can use it to pay
you. If they the cash leaves the company
that hurts you as a bond holder. So
what's good for stockholders is do you
see how as a stockholder in a company
you can exploit bond holders if they
don't protect themselves you could pay
yourself a special dividend half the
company. So what do bond holders do
usually if they're
sensible they'll put in covenants on how
much can be paid in dividends if they're
sensible. If they're not, then you
expose yourself to this kind of payout.
So there are good reasons and bad
reasons for paying dividends. And the in
the table I'm going to end this section
with ask CFOs what they factor in when
they decide on dividend policy from
number one all the way to number seven.
First, so if you look at the statement
of if you look at each of these
statements, they were asked, do you
agree? Do you disagree? A firm's
dividend payout ratio affects the price
of the stock. 61% agree. 33%. This is
the scariest number in the
middle because clearly what it is saying
we have no
idea dividend policy most CFOs just go
along with the rest of the peer group.
I'm going to talk about what because
they really have no idea how it affects
value. They've been told stories but
they have a sense that these stories
don't have sticking
power. So let's summarize. You know when
you look at dividends you can have two
bad reasons. One is that bird in the
hand fallacy that your stock will be
pushed up just because you pay
dividends. That turns out not to be true
empirically. The second is we had a
really good year. Let's start paying
dividends. The danger there is once you
get stuck with those dividends, you
might have to go out and raise capital
in future years. Just keep paying paying
the dividends. And three good reasons.
You got an investor base that likes what
you do and you're going to stick with
it. So you pay dividends. The second is
you use dividends as a signal to tell
the world, hey, our earnings are a lot
more predictable than you think they
are. Here's how we'll convince you.
We're going to go out and raise
dividends. And the third is that maybe
you're ripping off your bond holders
because they left a loophole for you to
take advantage
of. So now let's turn to the the because
up till now we haven't come up with a
framework of looking at your company
saying that should it pay more
dividends, less dividends, should it buy
back stock, not buy back stock. So I'm
going to give you two frameworks for
assessing dividend policy and in the
process maybe we can also answer the
question is your company the one that
should be paying more in dividends or
should it be the one buying back
stock. It's the first of these
frameworks I call the cash trust nexus.
Strange word to use in the context of a
finance class, right? You're saying
trust. I'm going to argue that dividend
policy more than any other aspect of
corporate finance is built on whether
you trust the management of the company
with your cash. Remember, we started
this discussion by saying dividends are
your cash, your stockholders in a
company. Apple is holding $200 billion
of your cash. Do you trust Apple's
management and Tim Cook to do the right
thing? That's going to drive what you do
about that cash. So we're going to talk
about how to measure cash flows and how
to measure trust. And the second is to
do what we did in capital structure.
Look at what everybody else is doing in
terms of paying dividends. I'm going to
try to do what they do because that way
I can't get into trouble. So let's start
with that cash trust nexus. And there
three subp parts, three sub steps to
this process. First step is an easy one.
I'm going to look at your past as a
company and I'm going to look at how
much cash you have returned as a
company. Have any of you had a chance to
look at how much cash your companies
have
returned? It's we're not might not be
there, but don't be surprised if your
company's returned no cash, right? That
doesn't make them abnormal. You might
actually be the norm, but your company
might have returned cash and either
dividends or buybacks. Where would you
find this information? In the statement
of cash flows. So that's going to be
easy looking at what your company's
return. Second step, we're going to ask
I think a more important question. How
much could my
company have returned to a shareholder?
Sounds like a complex question. It's
actually a very simple question and the
answers are right there in the statement
of cash flows. We're going to estimate
I'm going to give it an a free cash flow
to equity. Okay, essentially it's free
because you met every other need. It's a
cash flow because I'm going to convert
to cash flow and it's to equity because
that's the cash flow that equity
investors can get potential dividends.
And step three, if there's a mismatch
between what you returned and what you
could have returned, I'm going to ask,
does that mismatch hold up or should we
do something about it? So, let's start
with the first of the three questions,
the easiest one, which is how much cash
did my company return to its
shareholders over the last two years,
the last three years. You you're saying
why go back in time? Because with
dividends, you might get smooth numbers.
Buybacks since they spike and then they
drop. You might want to look at a
stretch of time. Here, I've looked at
five years leading into 2013. With each
company, I've looked at the dividends
they paid back. So, you look at Disney,
the dividends have have increased pretty
dramatically. But take a look at the
buybacks. Disney in the last 5 years has
returned about 19.9
billion, 15.4 4 billion in the form of
buybacks, 4.5 billion in the form of
dividends. If you look at VA, 24 billion
in dividends. That's a mind-bogglingly
high number. We talk about why it's so
high. And about 5.7 billion in buybacks.
So the buyback disease, if we can call
it, that is spreading across the world.
Motors all in dividends. They
haven't bought back stock. Bu 0. Now,
one of the things I want to caution you
is if you if your company doesn't return
cash, don't skip the dividend policy
section and give me the reason. My
company doesn't have dividends,
therefore there is no dividend policy. A
policy of not paying dividends is still
a dividend policy. You have to explain
to me whether it makes sense. BYU
doesn't return cash. We're going to come
back and take a look at does that make
sense given what they could have
returned. And lastly, I look at $4.4 4
billion in dividends. You can see the
drop off in dividends. Clearly,
something has happened at the company
that is getting in the way of them
paying
dividends. So, as I said, this is the
easy part of dividend assessment. You
just get it out of the statement of cash
flows and it captures how much your
company could have
returned. Now, let's talk about free
cash flow equity. I'm going to give you
an intuitive explanation of what we're
trying to measure with free cash equity.
And the best way to think about is to be
the owner of a privately owned business.
So you're the owner and I'm trying to
measure the cash left in the till at the
end of the year after you've met every
single need. So let's start with how you
measure income. You're an equity. You're
looking at equity investors. So how do
we measure income for equity investors?
What measure of income do we start
with? What are your choices? Gross
income, operating income, net income.
You start with net income, right? It's
not cash flow. So what's the first step?
You add back depreciation and
amortization. That makes it kind of
operating
earnings. Stay in that first section of
the statement of cash flows because
right below net income plus day no
depreciation amotization. I'm going to
go to Kelly because she's our resident
accountant. What comes right below the
depreciation amotization in that first
section of
operating capex shows up in the
investing section. Stay in the operating
section. There'll be change in account
receivables, change in payables, change
in working capital. Right? So basically,
you have change in working capital in
there. Then go to the investing section.
You're going to find
capex. Don't get distracted by the other
crap that's in there. Right? So it's
capex, maybe
acquisitions. Not quite done. So you've
added back depreciation. You've
subtracted capex. You've subtracted
change in working capital. You're the
equity investor, right? If you have debt
payments due, that's a cash
outflow. And if you raise debt, and this
throws people off, that's a cash inflow.
Think purely like you're running the
checkbook. You lend money, you you repay
debt, that's cash leaving the company,
you borrow money, cash comes into the
company. Think of that, the net debt
cash flow. That's going to be the
financing section. You put them all
together, you end up with free cash flow
equity. net income plus depreciation
minus capex minus change in working
capital and these net debt cash flows
give you free cash equity that is the
technical definition but I'm going to
give you two different spins on it
because intuitively one of those might
connect better if you take capex
depreciation working capital and put
them together that's what we call
reinvestment in valuation it's what the
company's putting back into the company
so instead of treating them as three
separate items you might say I'm going
to have net income minus
reinvestment minus this net debt cash
flow which can be either a positive or a
negative. So that's one split. You want
to consolidate even more. Take the net
debt that you issued state it as a
percentage of the total reinvestment.
You can state the reinvestment times one
minus the debt ratio. Basically that is
your equity portion in every single
scenario. What you end up with? So take
a company, try all three. You should get
the same answer. Just three ways of
framing free cash equity. So let's pause
right there and think a little bit about
what drives whether a company will have
a positive free cash equity, a zero free
cash rate equity, or a negative free
cash equity. Let's start at the
top. If your company's a money losing
company, you already know that this is
going to possibly be a company that
shouldn't be returning cash. It's kind
of intuitive, but might as well stay
with it. Why? Because you start in the
hole, you're going to get usually get
unless you have some huge devestages
you're doing. So negative net income you
but let's take the more interesting
case. You have a company that's making
positive net
income. What has to happen for a company
with positive net income to end up with
negative free cash or equity? The answer
is usually is right there. Right? What
has to be true about this company? Why
would a company with positive net income
end up with a negative free cash flow
equity? Yes, Derek.
One is huge debt payments. LBOS, you can
make net income, but since you have to
pay off the debt, the net debt cash flow
is going to be a big negative. That can
cause neg. But let's say you don't have
much in
debt. What else could cause net income
to translate to negative free cash flow
equity?
Yes,
large capex relative to depreciation.
Usually companies with large capex also
have large depreciation, right? Large
capex. You're saying when would that
happen? If you're a growing company,
remember depreciation reflects capex in
previous periods. Capex reflects your
much bigger scale right now. We're
talking about growth companies. Young
growth companies even when they start
making money will have negative free
cash flow equity.
And as you mature, here's what happens.
Not that your capex gets smaller, but
your depreciation starts to catch up.
And when it starts to catch up, that net
number, net capex, starts to get less
less of a burden. You end up with
positive free cash equity. You see the
life cycle starting to play out early in
the process. You're a young company,
usually money losing. Of course, you're
going to have negative free cash equity.
You're a growing company. your net
income starts to grow, but your
reinvestment is high because you still
want to invest for growth. You still
have negative free cash equity and you
hit that tipping point, you essentially
start to see free cash flows to equity
become
positive. It's a very simple process.
It's, you know, basically you're just
taking the statement of cash flows and
and re the accountants have their own
reasons for breaking things down the way
they do. You're just taking those
numbers and refraraming them from the
perspective, what does this tell me
about a company's dividend policy.
Remember, a statement of cash flows is
designed to do what? Explain the change
in the cash balance from year to year.
That's basically becomes the bottom
line. We're saying that's not my bottom
line. We're going to look at how much
you this company could have paid in in
dividends.
So as you look at this process and you
look at what happens especially as you
get to steady state right because this
you can do for the last 5 years last 10
years you can use all three approaches
they will give you the same answer but
remember your job is to forecast what
your company can afford to pay in the
future. So let's start at the top. You
got to forecast net income, right? You
go get growth rates from somewhere.
Forecast net income, capex,
depreciation, working capital, maybe
consolidate them and say this is a
growing company. 80% of my net income
goes into reinvestment. So you want when
you forecast things to keep it simple.
Less is more. And in fact, if you're
forecasting free cash flow equity, I
would just forecast three items. Net
income, reinvestment consolidated, and a
debt ratio.
saying over time I expect to raise 30%
of my reinvestment from debt 70% from
equity. So there's the shortcut net
income subtract out the net capex times
the equity portion of that and change it
will gives you a free cash equity and
you can compute that fairly simply if
you want to for the future. Why would
you want to do that to get a sense of
how much your company can return in cash
flows in the
future. So that's the way we compute
free cash equity. Any questions
intuitively about what we're trying to
do? This is the cash left in the till.
You can take it out of the the company
without hurting the company's value and
prospects. That's key. You can always
take out more, but if you do, you got to
go back and tell me how much lower your
growth is going to be because you took
out too much
cash. So for Disney, I computed the free
cash equity from 2008 to 2012. Start
with net income. So this are actual free
cash flow record. I'm not forecasting.
There's the net income over the five
years. There's the net capex over the
five years. And you can see net capex is
a hugely volatile number. And that's
something you're going to start to see
when you look at reinvestment is it's
not this nice smooth number. Some years
you reinvest a lot, some years don't
reinvest very much. And that's one
reason I'm looking across a period of
time rather than one year.
There's a change in working capital
again directly out of the statement of
cash flows. There's my free cash flow
equity before I even look at
debt. I don't know how many of you track
Warren Buffett's writings, but one of
the things that Warren Buffett talks
about is what he call calls owner's
earnings. And his definition of owner's
earnings is net income plus depreciation
minus capex.
So it's very close to this free cash
equity. He ignores working capital
because he thinks it's too volatile a
number. For many companies that
difference is going to be narrow enough.
If you're a retail, it could get you
into trouble. But he doesn't factor in
debt. His argument is a healthy company
shouldn't be drawing on debt to pay
dividends. I disagree with that. A
healthy growing company should be
borrowing money to fund its
reinvestment. It's not borrowing money
to pay dividends. But he stops with that
free cash. So I I just to give you a
sense of what that number would look
like, it's $17.3 billion if you didn't
factor in debt cash flows. Over this
period though, the net cash flow from
debt has been positive for the most
part. What does that mean? That Disney
has been borrowing more money than
they're repaying, which is actually
usually a sign of a healthy company. A
healthy company as it scales up should
be borrowing more money than it's
repaying. And the net debt adds another
9.8 billion. So if you add that on to
the 17 billion, you get $27 billion in
free cash
equity. The one reason Disney was
borrowing so much, it was underleveled
to start the process. And remember, if
you're underleveled, you're just you
should be borrowing more money. So I
tried a different calculation where I
said, if I just used a target debt
ratio, 11.58%, which is where they are,
and use that to fund my reinvestment,
what would my free cash rate equity be?
about 18 billion. So I've got three
different measures of free cash equity.
17.3 billion if I don't count debt cash
flows at all. 27.1 billion if I count
all of the debt cash flows, but they
were borrowing a lot of money during
this period or the 18 billion plus which
is kind of a smoothed out free cash flow
equity. They actually returned $19.9
billion. So they returned about $1.6 $6
billion more than they brought in as
free cash or equity. Is that a
gamebreaker of company this size? It's
not it's it's not that large of a
difference, but it does mean they're
returning all the cash they can and more
at least over this 5-year
period. So, that's basically what you're
trying to do with free cash equity. Look
at what your company could have paid
out. Look at what it actually paid out.
And then say, what do we do next?
I want to take a little pause though and
talk about what happens when companies
have large free cash flow equity and
they don't pay them
out. In the late '9s, Microsoft was on
its way to becoming the largest market
cap company in the world. G was still
larger but was just rising. And in 1996,
they had net income of 2.2
billion. Their capex was 494. the
depreciation was 480. If you take that
net number, it's 14 million. That sounds
like an absurdly low reinvestment,
right? But what am I missing when I look
at just that 14 million? What's what's
Microsoft's big reinvestment
in? Tapex captures land, building,
equipment, factories, but that's not
what Microsoft's reinvested. It's R&D,
and net income is already after R&D. So,
in a sense, it's a little deceptive. It
doesn't throw off my free cash equity.
My net income is understated. My
reinvestment is understated. The net
number is still the net number, but
that's a 14 million net capex. The
change in working capital is 35 million.
Again, a tiny number. You net out net
capex and change in working capital.
Their free cash flow equity was
$2.127
billion. That and at that time that was
a huge free cash equity. Everything
scaled up today.
They paid no
dividends and they bought back no stock.
So I have a very simple mechanical
question. If you have 2.127 billion in
free cash flow equity and you pay no
dividends and you buy back no
stock, where would I find that $2.127
billion on Microsoft's financial
statements? Yousef, you want to try
seeing? That's the answer you usually
get. But the wrong side of the balance
sheet, right? What's retained earnings?
It's net income minus. So on the
library, it's you're right. Book equity
will rise, but not by 2.127 billion.
Where do you think it'll go? Yep. It has
to there's only one place it can go on
the asset. It has to go into cash.
You're saying, why can't it go into R&D?
Because I start with net income. Net
income is already after R&D. Why can't
it be in capex? Because I've already
netted out capex.
The only place it can go is into the
cash balance. So the cash balance at
Microsoft increased by $2.1 billion in
96. In 97 they had three billion in free
cash equity. They returned nothing. So
that's another three billion on top of
what they had before. 1998 was a big
year. 5 billion. You saying why was it a
big year? Go back and look at all the
Windows years. Windows 98. Because
that's that used to be their core
business, right? Every time you did an
upgrade, they got 5 billion in free cash
flow equity paid out nothing. And now
the f you you see what's going to
happen, right? Two plus three plus five.
And each year you keep building up by
the time you get to 2000, Microsoft had
the largest cash balance in corporate
history at that time. It's about $40
billion. But when you see companies end
up with big cash balances and CFOs claim
to be surprised about how it
happened, my response is, what do you
think? It's mana from heaven that landed
up on your balance sheet. This is a
direct consequence of not paying out
what you can afford. I'm not passing
judgment on whether it's good or bad
yet, but we know how Apple ends up with
200 billion cash. And to give Apple
credit, Apple has returned a half a
trillion dollars in buybacks over the
last six years, and still its cash
balance goes up. That's a great problem
to have as a company, right? You keep
funneling out cash, but more cash keeps
coming
in. Apple's trying, but its cash balance
is rising because it's free cash. It's a
cash machine. The iPhone is the greatest
cash machine in history in terms of how
much cash it has created for Apple as a
company.
So when you look at free cash flow
equity and you don't see that cash
return, there's only one place for it to
go. The cash balance builds up. Remember
I said last session that a lot of tech
companies don't start to pay dividends
even though they can afford to because
they want to be young again and be
growth companies
forever. You look at big tech companies
almost every one of them. Google has a
100red billion.
Some of them try now they try to return
Facebook and Google in fact this year
initiated
dividends that's and I think I've said
this before when a growth company
initiates dividends it's like when you
decide to switch from c from jeans to
khakis you're sending a signal out
saying you know what I'm shopping at the
gap from now on you know I I I I'm too
old for this stuff it's a signal to the
world I am middle-aged There's nothing
wrong with signaling the truth and it's
actually it's it's actually good for
Google and Facebook to do it because
what are they trying to do? Bring down
unrealistic expectations the part of
investors who think they can grow. I
mean when I hear people saying Apple can
grow 20% a year in what universe is that
going to even happen? Maybe they can
pull out pull it off for one year. These
companies are great cash
machines but their growth rates are
leveling. In fact, they're great cash
machines precisely because their growth
is leveling off. Do you see the
connection there? Cuz your growth
leveling off means you reinvest less. If
you reinvest less, you have a higher
free cash flow
equity. Now the question is, can you
compute the free cash flow equity for a
bank? Do you remember our discussion of
capital structure for a bank? What do we
say? You can't tell whether a bank has
too much debt or too little debt. But
you can tell whether it has too much
equity or too little equity relative to
what? to regulatory capital. In fact, we
defined what a bank can borrow by
looking at how much it has to set aside
for regulatory capital. I'm going to
stick with that theme. If you ask me to
estimate the free cash or equity for a
bank, I'm going to start with net
income. That's still the starting point.
But rather than look at capex and
depreciation working capital, which will
take me nowhere for a bank, I'm actually
going to look at how much they will have
to invest in regulatory capital as a
bank. And that's going to become my
equivalent of reinvestment. That's it.
I'm done. Net income minus reinvestment
regulatory capital. Let's step step back
and think about what kinds of banks then
can pay out high dividends. And what
kinds of banks can pay lower dividends?
High growth banks versus low growth
banks. Which should pay the higher
dividends? And what is it about the low
growth banks that allows them to pay
high
dividends? the regulatory capital
doesn't have to rise much, right?
Because if you're growing 2% a year,
your regulatory capital needs are going
to be small. So other things remaining
equal. And so you're saying that's
pretty
obvious. You in banks are often
classified based on their
capitalization, under capitalized versus
overc capitalized bank. And let's be
very clear when we talk about under or
over capitalized bank, we're talking
about regulatory capital or equity
capital.
So, let's say you're looking at a bank
that is under capitalized versus one
that's over capitalized. They're both
mature
banks. You can already see the
consequences, right? If you're an underc
capitalapitalized bank, even though
you're not growing, you have to come up
with investments in regulatory capital
to get back to steady state. You can
essentially see the effect on your
reinvestment, your free cash equity.
Let's take a third scenario. Let's
suppose that the Fed increases
regulatory capital requirements for all
banks. What is it going to mean? All
banks are now going to have less free
cash flow equity than they used to. They
can continue to pay dividends like they
used to, but they're going to get into
trouble if they
do. It gives you a way of thinking about
how much can banks return to their
investors and the free cash flow equity
will therefore vary across banks. And
because when you talk to equity research
analysts, they say banks can return
their earnings as dividends. No, they
can't because if they did that, they'd
have regulatory problems if especially
the growing banks or under capitalized
banks. So with Deutsche, I actually
looked at the free cash equity and you
can see that the bank is in deep
trouble, right? you look at the each
year and this is based on so this I'm
forecasting free cash equity because
they were already in trouble and saying
and they were paying dividends and it
made no sense to me because everybody
knew they're in trouble and when you
compute the free cash equity it was
negative we'll talk about why companies
with negative free cash flow equity
might continue to pay dividends but they
were so I forecast out the free and this
is a optimistic scenario you can see
they will need to invest huge amounts in
regulatory capital to get back to steady
state, which means their free cash
equity will continue to be negative for
the next 3 years. Eventually, can they
pay dividends? Yes, if things work
out. But banks in particular, I think,
have some of the most insane dividend
policies in the world where they get
stuck paying dividends. and and we'll
I'll give you all the reasons I hear
from bank CFOs as to why they can't
afford to cut dividends and why they
shouldn't be cutting
dividends especially when everybody
knows they have negative free cash flows
equity because of the regulatory capital
needs. So every year at the start of the
year when I do my data data analysis one
of the things I do is I compute the free
cash equity for every company in the
world. Sounds like a lot of work, but
it's just an column in the Excel
spreadsheet, right? Net income plus
depreciation minus capex, you know,
minus change in working capital minus
net cash flow. So I compute the free
cash flow, free cash flow equity for
every company. Then I look at the
dividends and buybacks in that
statement, same statement of cash flows,
and I compare the two numbers. What am I
trying to figure out? Are companies
paying out less than or more than they
can afford to? And I've broken it down
by region and make of it whatever you
want. So first I broke companies down
based on whether they made money or lost
money and looked at what percentage of
each group pay dividends. I mean even
without looking at the statistics saying
why would money losing companies pay
dividends. No it is true money-making
companies are more likely to be dividend
payers than money losing companies. But
if you look across money losing
companies that number is definitely not
zero. There are lots of money losing
companies that continue to pay
dividends. I also broke companies down
by based on free cash flow equity,
positive, negative. And remember, we
said negative free cash flows equity
shouldn't pay dividends. Again, the
overall statistics support the idea
companies with positive free cash flows
equity are more likely to pay dividends
than companies with negative free cash
flow equity. But a significant
percentage globally 36% of companies
with negative free cashless equity are
returning
cash to their
shareholders. So let's look at these
disconnects, right? First, let's look at
why a company which is money losing
might continue to pay dividends. And I
list out reasons and they range from
sensible to not so sensible. First is
inertia.
What is inertia capture? Why these
companies paying dividends? Because
they've always paid chat GPT is running
the company. It's looking at last year's
dividend paid this year. Why I'm paying
money to have a CFO in the company
completely? No, I I don't even see the
point here. It's inertia. It could be
that they worry about sending a bad
signal. Remember that that picture I
showed you?
This is actually the argument that bank
CFOs often give for why they don't want
to cut dividends in the face of
calamity.
2009 was a horrifically bad year for US
banks. Every one of them is in trouble.
75% of US banks continued to pay
dividends in
2009. Remember talking to the CFO of a
pretty large bank. He said, "Why are you
guys paying dividends? Everybody knows
you're in trouble." He said, "We don't
want to send a negative signal." I said,
"What universe are you in?" Every day I
open up the Wall Street Journal, I get
the news that I mean, when you pay a
dividend, what it tells me is you're in
denial rather than anything else because
everybody knows you're in trouble.
Signaling the truth is never wrong. In
fact, if you're in trouble, it's better
take your medicine, say, "We can't
afford to pay dividends." But they hold
on. A third argument is they hope for a
bounce back. Right? We talked about
commodity companies, you bounce back.
So, okay, if you're a company in a
cycle, in a business that's cyclical.
And the fourth, and this goes with the
second reason, is everybody else pays
dividends. I know we're in trouble, but
we don't want to be different. This
sounds like a six-year-old is running
the company, right? And a lot of
dividend policy, you look and say, is
there a grown-up in this room? But it's
almost like dividend policies set by
looking at the pure group and doing what
they do. So that's money losing
companies that pay a dividend. Let's
look at the other side of the spectrum.
Why would a money making company not
return cash to its investors? First is
inertia again. Why are you not paying
dividends? Because we've never paid
dividends. Okay, that's deep. I'll take
it and and move on. The second is, and
this is a more sensible thing, is net
income is profits. We need to reinvest
to grow. And we're reinvesting so much
that after we reinvest, we don't have
cash return. Remember, I'm we're talking
about income, not free cash equity. The
third is my income looks good now, but I
don't want to return cash because
there's a tariff coming and who knows
what my earnings will look like next
year.
The fourth is remember when cash leaves
the company you no longer control it as
managers. So be honest with me as a
manager. Isn't it nice to be sitting on
billion? Everybody pays attention to you
especially
bankers. You give that cash back. It's
out of your hands. This goes back to
that first discussion we had on
corporate
governance. How much power do you have
as managers? And I will wag it that in
markets with poor corporate governance,
more cash is held back by companies
because you really can't get to the
cash. So that's net income and
dividends. Let's focus on free cash rate
equity. Again, why won't negative free
cash flow equity firms pay return cash?
Again, inertia hopes for a bounce back
in the free cash cyclical firms. The
third is actually something to think
about. Remember this follows our
analysis of whether you have you know
excess debt capacity. If you're an
underlevered firm, what does that mean?
Your actual debt ratio is well below the
optimum. One of the ways you might be
able to push your debt ratio up is by
returning more cash than you have
available in free. It actually makes
sense because over time your equity will
shrink, your debt will go up and your
debt ratio will go up. So capital
structure and dividend policy are
actually connected on that basis. So
when you look at your company's dividend
policy, also look at do they have excess
debt capacity. And finally, if you're in
that that portion of the life cycle
where your best days are way behind you,
then maybe the best thing to do is make
yourself smaller over time. And that if
you return more than your free cash flow
every year, you're partially liquidating
yourself every year and making yourself
a smaller company.
So that's why negative free cash or
equity sometimes return cash. Let's talk
about why positive free cash or equities
sometimes don't pay return cash. One is
again
inertia.
Second did I copy the same thing here?
So again the bounceback effect in the
other direction right which is my free
cash flow equity is positive right now
but what happens if I have a bad year?
So essentially it's the opposite of the
bounce back argument. Third is if you're
over 11, if you conclude your firm is
over 11, when you get positive free cash
equity, you don't want to return it to
your shareholders. You want to use it to
pay down debt because that's becomes
your first priority. And finally, if you
have expansion plans, you want to keep
that free cash or equity for that big
investment you got to make, the
acquisition you're going to make a year
or two from now.
So as you look across companies and
especially as you look at your own
company when you look at that free cash
or equity over time and what your ca
company returned you'll almost never see
that perfect cash return where your free
cash equity gets returned. Your company
will either return too much or return
too little. Okay. And don't be too quick
to judge them because you got to know
look at that in the context of their,
you know, what their earnings do over
time, what their capital structure looks
like. But cash return and free cash flow
equity can be
mismatched. So we talked about what
happens when a company has big free cash
flow equity and it doesn't return the
cash, right? Your cash balance builds
up.
Apple, it's $200 billion, but investors
seem to be okay with it, at least for
the moment. And I'm going to add that on
every time I say investors are okay for
the moment because that can
change. But once in a while, you'll
accumulate cash as a company and
investors are not going to be okay with
it. So, I'll take you back to the
1980s and look at a company that used to
be called Chrysler.
God only knows what name it is called
under
house. Stellantis would be how you come
up who I mean they probably paid
millions of dollars for this name. Who'd
want to buy a car made by Stellantis?
You
know, but I guess they thought it was
some neat name. Made them sound
technical. Chrysler in the early 80s
almost went
bankrupt. It was one of the first
bailouts. In fact, the US government
bailed out. one of the first corporate
bailouts in the
US. And in
1985, it actually was starting to it got
a new CEO. It had zero cash balance. Its
cash balance had gone down to zero. The
new CEO's name was Liia
Koka and he reinvented the company
around a vehicle that I still curse
every time I pull into a mall.
You know what Chrysler created that
allowed it to make a comeback?
The Dodge
Caravan. The first minivan. And if you
want to see what minivans look like,
pre- Dodge Caravan, take a look at the
old
Volkswagen buses. It's basically you
threw people into the back. I don't even
think there were seats. You hope they
didn't get too hurt as they got thrown
around. But the Dodge Caravan reinvented
Chrysler and Chrysler rode it to
success. So in this graph, here's what
I've done. I've taken the net income
each year. That's a white column. And
the black column is the dividends they
paid each year. So 1985, they had 1.5
billion in free cash equity and paid out
very little in dividends. What happens
your cash balance? So each year what I'm
doing is tracking the free cash equity
and dividends. Taking the difference,
putting it into the cash balance.
So over time, their cash balance goes
up. There was a recession somewhere in
the middle, but they kind of made it
through. And by the time you get to
1994, Chrysler had accumulated a cash
balance of $8.5 billion. That doesn't
sound like much relative to what Apple
has, right? 200 billion. But at that
time, Chrysler's entire market value as
a company was about 30 billion. So think
about what you have. More than 25% of
the company was cash.
And a guy called Kirk
Koran noticed the cash. I still remember
because you know he got a press
conference and he's in the entire tenor
of the conference is Chrysler has too
much
cash. They need to return the
cash shades of what Carl Ian does at a
lot of companies right you have too much
cash give me the cash. What do you think
Chrysler's response to that was?
No, no, this is not too much cash. And
they gave a bunch of reasons, most of
which didn't stand up. First, they said,
"We're a cyclical company. We need the
cash." What part of that statement is
true? Cyclical company is
true. But do you need 8.5 billion cash?
In fact, you can very quickly start to
debunk how much they need because there
is a recession during this period. And
how much cash did they burn through?
They start about three billion. They got
to 200. So they burnt out burnt through
about a half a billion in cash in the
last recession which lasted 2 years. So
let's do an algebra problem. If the last
recession lasted 2 years and you burnt
through a half a billion in cash, how
long does the next recession have to
last for you to need 8 12 billion in
cash? Like 34 years. So you're planning
for a 34 year recession. That's what
you're doing. It's like a guy who goes
into his backyard and starts building an
arc. Every time it starts drizzling,
saying this could be the big
one. I can understand you're a cyclical
firm. You want to hold a billion in
cash, maybe a billion and a half. 8.5
billion is way too much. So they very
quickly realized this wasn't working. So
they came back with a second reason.
They said, "We might need it in case we
decide to do a big acquisition." This is
making you feel a lot better as Chrysler
shareholders, right? What's the history
of companies doing big acquisitions? We
kind of talked about at the start of the
class. What do they do? They get great
bargains or they
overpay. In fact, no, in my valuation
class, I'm going to do the session on on
acquisitions. The title of the session
is acquirers anonymous, seven steps to
sobriety because acquisitions are like
an addiction. You buy a company, you
stop taking projects, right? It's so
much work. you take one big
acquisition. That didn't work very well
either because people said, "We don't
want you to be doing a big acquisition.
You can't build an assembly plant. How
the heck are you going to buy an entire
company?" The bottom line was finally
Chrysler had to give
it. They gave, you know, Koran a seat on
the board. They returned more than half
of the cash to their shareholders. But
the point here is they came under
pressure because of who they were. They
were Chrysler and they were in a
business, the automobile business where
people realize there wasn't much in
terms of growth. This is not a great
business to be in. And already you can
see the setting. Microsoft in 2000 had
40 billion cash. Nobody brought that up
as a big cash balance. Why? Because they
looked at Microsoft's history. They
looked at the business which is still a
growing business. say, "In this company,
I'm okay with Microsoft holding my
cash." They look at Chrysler with 8.5
billion cash, they come to a very
different
judgment. That's the trust part. If you
trust management to not waste your cash,
you trust management because a company's
in a good business, you trust management
because they have a good track record,
you're more likely to cut them slack in
terms of how much cash you will allow
them to have. Conversely, if you don't
trust
them and everything starts to come apart
at the
seams, you trust Facebook with your
cash. It's ebbed and flowed, right?
Early on, what what was the view? Mark
Zuckerberg is a genius. Look, he wears a
sweatshirt for his IPO. That must mean
he's a genius, right? And for the first
six or seven years, founder worship
kicked in, right? Great CEO, great know.
And then he did the metaverse dance and
people said, "This guy has no idea what
he's doing. He likes to spend a lot of
money and he's not telling us what to
do." Period. In 2021 where people said,
"Give me all the cash back. We don't
trust you with the cash." That was the
absolute bottom. And to give Facebook
credit, I'm you know what they did right
after, right? They did a big stock
buyback. Say, "You guys are right. We
have no idea what we're doing, but we're
going to reearn the trust."
and he has by being much more careful.
He, if you notice, he doesn't talk about
the metaverse much anymore. Even AI is a
lot more muted than he might have been 5
years ago. Cuz I and I, you know, that's
why I think we need to give this guy
credit for being somebody who senses
what markets want and change is a
student rather than going like a bull in
a china
shop. It's about trust. So if you ask
me, is my cash balance too large? I'm
going to say, do investors trust you? If
they trust you, they're going to let you
hold the cash. It doesn't I mean, I'm an
Apple stockholder. You know why I feel
okay with Apple holding 200 billion my
cash? How many large acquisitions has
Apple made in the last 10
years? None. Not one. You think what
about Beats acquisition? You know what
what it cost them to buy Beats? Like $5
billion. That's like petty cash. Nobody
probably even noticed. Oh, 5 billion
left. We have so much cash. No, just let
it
go. You imagine how much pressure Apple
must be under to acquire companies. They
probably built a motor around one
infinity loop to keep bankers
out. There's a probably teams of bankers
with another target for them. We got a
perfect company for you. And that is
amazing discipline for a company to not
do. And what did they with AI? You see
the same kind of discipline, right?
What's Mera doing? Spending $60 billion.
Microsoft 75 billion. Apple says, "Wait,
do you really think this is going to?"
And people take issue with them. You're
being too cautious. I think what Apple
is doing in AI is in fact the better
strategy because why jump in before you
even know whether you need these big AI
chips? What if deepseek is really the
way to go? With lowgrade chips and less
data, you can deliver 95% of what you
want. The reason I trust Apple for the
moment is because they haven't done
anything
stupid. If tomorrow they announce we're
buying
Tesla, they
could maybe the price drops another
$50, then I'm out of the door, right?
Because in a sense, that's where trust
gets broken in big acquisitions where
man says, "Trust us. We know what we're
doing." My response is no I I came close
to selling Microsoft when they bought
Activision. The only reason I didn't was
Activision was small at 76 billion
saying 76 billion small when you're 2.5
trillion dollar company 76 billion
become
small but it was a bad acquisition in
hindsight. I don't think it helped
Microsoft any and but they got caught in
because they got started the deal and
stuff to walk away.
So here's what I'd like you to do for
your company. And as I said, this is the
simplest of the the the different things
you got to do for the class. Estimate
the free cash flows to equity for your
company. Stay with that statement of
cash flows. And the statement of cash
flows, remember the sign is already
there, right? So capex will have a
negative in front of it. Don't you know?
So basically in the same cash flows, you
just take all of the numbers and
accumulate them. It'll take care of
itself. Look at what your company could
have returned.
and then look at what it actually did
return and say the same same statement
of cash flows. Repurchase the stock and
the dividends will be in there and do it
over five maybe five years, three years.
If your company's been around only three
years, do it for those three years. You
have no choice but it's been around
longer. Look across time. You want to
look at trend lines. You can look at
what the company can because you're
trying to get a sense of what is my
company's policy.
So I'm going to set up a framework for
assessing dividend policy and maybe this
will help you in with your company. So
let's say you compute the free cash
equity for your company over 5 years, 10
years, whatever you want to do. Then you
look at what they actually return the
form of dividends and buybacks. One of
three things is going to be true once
you've done that computation. One is
your company is one of those very rare
companies that actually returns its free
cash or equity to shareholders either as
dividends or buybacks. Coned, for
instance, returns about 97% of its free
cash equity to its
shareholders. But that's the exception.
You're going to have one of two cases
for most of you. Your company can either
be paying out too much in dividends or
too little in
dividends. Let's take each and play it
through. And let's look at whether you'd
push the company to change what it does.
If it pays too much in dividends, then
ask a follow-up question. What kind of
investment opportunities are there for
this company? You can look at the return
on capital you computed what seven
sessions ago for your company and look
at it versus the cost of capital. But
make an assessment. Am I in a growth
business or a mature
business? If you're in a growth business
and you have great investments, then my
advice to the company is go out and take
good projects and you know because if
you pay too much in dividends
essentially you're going to have that.
But if you pay too little, I'm
essentially going to cut them slack,
saying you're going to find good
investments. Hold on to the
cash. But if your investment history is
checkered, you haven't earned your cost
of cap for the last 10 years. You're
accumulating
cash. This is just common sense. You're
going to put pressure on this company,
right? So don't pick on Carl I can when
he does that for you because somebody's
got to be the bad guy in this process
saying you guys need to return the
cash. So if you have accumulated cash
because you paid too little in dividends
the key becomes are you in a good
business and do I trust you as a manager
with your track record? If I do trust
you I'm going to let you hold on to the
cash and if I don't trust
you I'm going to try to put pressure. If
I don't, I'm praying and hoping that
Carl I can will put the pressure on you
to give the cash back. So that's if you
pay too little in
dividends. If the company I'm
sorry, if you pay too much in dividends,
let's see what the consequences are.
Again, I'm going to ask you, do you have
good projects? If you have good projects
and you're paying too much in dividends,
you're doing double damage to yourself,
right? In addition to cy creating this
cash deficit, you might be rejecting
some of those investments because you
don't have the
cash here. I'm actually going to
actively ask you to invest, you know,
pay out less in dividends and redirect
that money to those good investments.
Why? Because then I get the net present
value of the projects and you no longer
have a dividend
problem. And there's a final scenario.
Let's say you're paying too much in
dividends and you're in a bad business.
You see why there's no easy advice to
give you? Ask this company to cut
dividends. What are you afraid they
might do? Take the cash and put more
into the bad business, right? This
company has a problem, but it's not a
dividend problem. It's an investment
problem. The if they don't fix the
investment problem, fixing the dividend
problem is going to be cosmetic, right?
You cut dividends, you're going to be
back into the problem because you keep
taking bad projects. So here you got to
do two things. One is you got to go back
to the investment section, say, "Hey,
the way you pick projects is not
working. You're taking a bad lot of bad
projects." Cut back on that. Maybe
that'll make your dividend problem go
away. And if it doesn't, cut dividends.
So, let's summarize. Your company pays
too little in dividends, has great
projects, you trust the management,
you're going to you're going to give the
company a pass. You can say, "This
company has a big cash balance. I'm okay
with that." The Apple scenario, your
company pays out too little in
dividends. it has bad
projects, then you're going to push for
the cash to be returned. So, this is the
the scenario where activist investors
put pressure on you to return cash or
you put pressure. If your company pays
too much in dividends is great projects,
you try to get the company to return
less cash even though everybody else in
the peer group might be paying those
dividends and you invest more in
projects. your company pays too much in
dividends, there's bad projects, it's
got to fix its project problem and the
dividend problem together or it's going
to be back into that same
problem. So that's the framework I'm
going to use and I you know I like to
think of it in terms of a matrix where
basically on on one on one axis I have
whether the cash returned is less than
or more than the free cash equity in the
other one whether you have good projects
or bad projects. So let's see what
quadrant you would put Apple in. Good
projects. Yeah, you can look at the
track record. The company earns 30, 35,
40% returns. Cash return less than free
cash equity. Yes, but I'm not worried
about it because I'm going to give them
the maximum flexibility because they've
earned that
flexibility. You go to this quadrant
right across you have a cash deficit and
poor projects. Think of this as your
worst possible quadrant because here you
have two problems. you dividend problem
and even investment problem and unless
you fix both together, you're going to
be back into that same
problem. The other two quadrants are the
interesting one because a cash surplus
and poor projects, that's the kind of
company going to put pressure on the
company to give the cash back because
you don't want that money going into
poor projects. And if you have cash
deficit and good projects, you want that
cash to go into the projects, right? And
if you have if you and if you're paying
too much in dividends, that prevents you
from taking projects, you're going to
ask them to cut dividends if you can.
So, what I'd like to do actually is take
you through each of the companies I'm
analyzing and I'm going to ask you to
play the role of shareholders in the
company and I'm going to play the role
of the CEO of the company and I'm going
to get up in front of you and said,
"Trust me." And I'm going to let you
make a judgment on whether you would
trust me. Right?
So let you know Microsoft in 2000 I said
had a $43 billion cash balance largest
cash balance at the time and there was
no real push back against them. They
were because they had a history of
delivering great projects and then
things changed when the justice
department actually targeted them. This
was 24 23 years ago for a breakup. got
ve they got very close to breaking up
Microsoft into Office and Windows as
separate companies. It didn't come to
fruition but
that changed the dynamics because people
start to worry about cash and what
Microsoft would do. And to give
Microsoft credit in 2004 they paid a
special dividend of 33 billion which
that time was the largest dividend paid
by US company in history.
What I'm trying to say is good companies
respond to market pressure not by
lecturing the market on how short-term
it is, but by saying guys, and that's
why I liked what Facebook did in the
aftermath of the metaverse. They said,
"We screwed up, and here's how we're
going to show we screwed up. We're going
to return some of your cash back to you
because it's your cash, and we'll try to
earn the right to get that cash back by
returning to taking good investments."
So let's start with Disney in 2003. Long
long time ago, but if you remember, this
was when Michael Eisner was still CEO of
the company. So you got sh you guys are
shareholders at Disney. It's 2003. I'm
going to set the table. Between 1994 and
2003, Disney generated 969 million in
free cash road equity over that
accumulated period. They returned 639
million in dividends and buybacks over
that same period. Right? So you take
that difference, $330 million every year
that they're holding back. 330 million
times 10 years is going to give you 3.3
billion. You add interest on top of it,
you're very quickly getting to 4
billion. So by the time you come to this
this annual meeting, Disney has
accumulated about $4 billion in cash.
It's your cash, right? So I'm going to
be Michael Eisner. I'm going to get up
there and ask you to trust me with your
cash in a moment of you've seen that Jim
Carrey movie where he can't tell a lie.
It's it's a if you've never seen it.
Let's say Michael Eisen has the same
disease. He gets up there and without
meaning to do it, he also reveals what
he's done for the last 10 years, which
is over the last 10 years, Disney's
generated return in equity on its
projects about 2% less than its cost of
equity. It's also underd delivered, you
know, um underdelled on its stock. So,
stock price has underperformed the
market. It's return equity is less than
the cost of
equity. And I'm the guy who's been in
charge of the company for those 10
years. So, what am I asking you to
do? To trust
me. Remember this, you know, you can
make judgments on either side. I'm sure
there'll be disagreement but I don't
have a strong hand here because my track
record is going to in fact if you add on
top of it two things. One is that during
this period Disney did an acquisition of
Cap City's ABC which completely blew up
on them driven largely by Michael
Eisner's
ego. You got the setting for a
blowback in 2003. I'll wager if this had
come up for a vote. If you could
actually vote in dividend policy, which
you're not, my guess is shareholders
said, "Give me the cash
back." And the fact that it's Michael
Eisner would have made it more likely.
You know what the lesson for this is? In
good times, CEOs sometimes treat their
shareholders with
contempt. Why? Because they don't need
them, right? Burns. it'll come back to
haunt you because there will be a time
when those shareholders will pass
judgment on
you. So your job as a CEO in the good
times is treat your shareholders well,
treat them with respect because then
when times are bad, you can say, "Hey,
no." And the more you let your ego drive
decisions, the more likely you're going
to be in Eisner's place. That was 2003.
Disney had lost all control of its
dividend
policy. Investors were putting pressure.
They had to return more cash.
Eventually, this ended up with Eisner
leaving the company or getting pushed
out and was replaced by Bob Iger. So,
let's fast forward to 200, you know. So,
in 2003, the bottom line is Disney had
no control because of the decision
they'd made leading into 2003. Zero
control over dividend policy, lots of
pressure to give the cash back. Fast
forward to
2009, new CEOs come in and at least in
the early years, Bob Iger did all the
right things. Remember, he shrunk the
board from 17 members down to 10. He
made it more independent. He actually
listened to shareholders, seemed to have
this, you know, small ego and he'd
announced that he was going to retire in
2011 or 12 because he felt that that was
the right time for in hindsight turned
out to be not true. that time. So in
2009 he looked at at the company. It had
a new CEO. Its stock price performance
had improved fairly dramatically between
2003 and 2009. Its return on capital and
return equity had risen above the cost
of equity and
capital. And now as IER I'm going to
come in front of you and say look for
the last 5 years I've been returning
more cash than have available as free
cash equity. I need this cash to build
new theme parks in China because that's
where the growth is going to be. We need
more money because we want to buy other
movie studios like you know Lucas Films
are still being talked
about and I gave you the chance of
voting again. My guess is most of you
would act differently in 2009 than in
2003. What I'm trying to say is
companies earn the right to hold
cash for a while, but you have to earn
the right. Nobody's endowed the right.
So when managers act like the cash is
theirs and that shareholders asking for
the cash are somehow doing a disservice,
they're missing the point. You earn the
right to hold cash. And if you lose that
right, then you got to earn it back
again. So
2003 to 2009, you can see the shift. And
the shift happened because of
performance because you you know that
Jensen's alpha that you computed 10
weeks ago comes into play. The return on
capital comes into play. So if you have
a company with a negative Jensen's alpha
and a negative return on capital, a
return capital less than the cost of
capital, this part of the analysis is
going to become pretty much of a slam
dunk. This company is not going to be
trusted and there's going to be pressure
on it to return cash. They might not
have to, but that pressure is going to
build up.
2013 things start to shift again. Yeah.
Why? Because remember that 2011
retirement had come and gone. I was back
again. The corporate governance was
starting to get shaky. The board was
starting to get become an aigger board
again. I think that if I asked you for
permission 2013, you'd be less eager
than in 2009 because you think, you
know, we don't feel as secure about your
judgments here.
What do you think about Bob Iger in
2025? Where does he stand in terms of
trust? You
think first he left right at the heart
of co right he claimed he was leaving I
don't even know what the reasons he gave
to have a restful
life. I think he actually he kept his
office in the Disney building in
Burbank, which is not a good thing to do
if you're a CEO that claims to be
leaving. And then he anointed Bob Chapek
as his successor. And then two years
later, he was
back and Disney is kind of changed as a
company. The entertainment business is
now broken officially. Nobody knows how
to put it back together again.
Disney Plus was out of control and this
of course rose, you know, gave rise to
that activist investing push you saw in
2020. I think Iger has responded well to
it because he's cut back the money spent
on far fewer shows in Disney Plus than
they used to be. He's kind of responded
in the right ways. Some of the pressure
is off, but you can see that Disney is
on
probation, right? They're being
watched. And I think that I knows that.
And of course, what's the big next big
date for Disney? What when does I what
what does I said? When is he claiming
he's leaving? What
year? I think 2026 or he said I'm gone
in 2026. We'll see if that holds. My
guess is if that doesn't hold and he's
still around in 2028 or 2029, we'll have
a problem again at Disney. And basically
with the company, you can see these es
and flows over time where people trust
you, you get the right to accumulate
cash. and people don't trust you, you're
going to see pressure on you either from
investors or activist investors. And if
you're a good management, you got to
kind of respond to that trust without
getting defensive. Because when people
lose trust in you, you can't talk them
back to trusting you. You got to
deliver. And I think that's what Disney
has to do now in terms of earning that
trust back so it can go back to
accumulating cash and controlling its
own dividend policy.
Take a second company, Vale. It's been a
long time. So, let me remind you again
what Vale does. It's a mining company.
It's a Brazilian company. It used to be
owned by the Brazilian government a
while back before it was privatized. And
if you remember the corporate governance
structure, Valle has, you know, two
classes of shares, voting and non-
voting shares. And on the non- voting
shares which are called preferred
shares, it has to pay a fixed dividend.
And if it fails to pay that
dividend, then it has to give those
shareholders voting rights. So keep that
in the background because Valet
definitely has a dividend problem. It's
a huge dividend problem. It's free cash
flow equity. No, even if you give it the
best possible spend is, you know, it's
negative. If you just use the actual
debt ratio, you use the target debt
ratio. It's about 13 billion, but
they're returning about $30 million cash
mostly in
dividends. It's not even debatable. The
company's paying out much more than it
can afford to in dividends. And it's not
underleveled. So, you can't even look
look for that escape hatch. Remember, it
was overlevered when we did the optimal
debt
ratio. Everybody at Valet knows there's
a dividend problem. So, I'm going to be
the CEO of Valet. you're going to be
valet
shareholders and I'm going to get up
there and make a plea which is guys we
can't afford to pay these
dividends. We're going to cut
dividends but most of you own what kind
of
shares? Those preferred
shares where you get no voting rights,
right? You run some quit core pro I
would think from this
process. I want to cut
dividends. What would you like in
return? Some voting rights. Right?
Essentially, I'm asking you to trade
off. Do you want to continue with this
insane dividend policy which you can't
afford or do you want to give up some
control? Guess what companies
consistently seem to
pick? Pick control. They'd rather drive
themselves into the ditch paying out
dividends they can't afford to than give
up voting rights to the preferred
shareholders. Petro Brass had this
problem multiplied. It almost went
bankrupt because it continued to pay
dividends which it couldn't afford
to. But it becomes this contest between
do you want to give up some control and
get back to sanity on your dividend
policy or do you want to keep control
and keep paying these dividends?
Companies consistently seem to pick
control. So Val is actually a classic
case study. What happens when you have
different class of shares and dividends
are essentially what are keeping the
non- voting shares non- voting and you
can't afford to pay those dividends. You
might never see
action this lifetime.
Just as a tangent, there are couple of
countries Chile I think had for a while
where companies and in Europe they were
talking about this. I think in one
French election this was one of the big
issues. One of the candidates wanted to
mandate that every company had to pay
out 35% of its earnings as dividends.
I don't know what passes through
politicians heads when they think about
dividend
policy, but let's think through the
consequences of what will happen if you
make every company in a market pay out
35 or 40% of its earnings as dividends.
Take the US market. Let's suppose the
law is passed that every company has to
pay out 40% of its earnings as
dividends. You say, why would I want to
do that? God only knows. Maybe you want
to collect more in taxes. Maybe you have
some weird explanation of what happens
to those
dividends. I want to think about what
kinds of companies are going to be most
negatively
affected by this policy. So I'll give
you the choices. Remember the the the
requirement is you pay 40% of your
earnings as dividends. Large companies
making huge profits, you think they'll
be
affected. Can Philip Morris afford to
pay 40% of its earnings as dividends?
Yeah, it already pays 55% of its
earnings as dividends. It's not
affecting the Philip Morrises, the
Coca-Cas. They already are mature
companies with lots of cash flows. What
about small companies losing
money? Keyword is losing money, right?
They have negative earnings, so they're
not affected. High growth companies that
are losing money. Again, if you're
losing money, I don't care. But what if
you're high growth companies that are
making money? What am I making you do?
pay out 40% of the earnings as
dividends, right? But you're a high
growth company. What do your free
cashless equity look like? They're
negative. I'm making you pay dividends
when you can least afford
to. You know who likes this
policy? Those large companies which are
mature because what does it do? It
handicaps your competition, right? By
making high growth companies pay out
dividends, you're effectively making
them less competitive in the space.
They'll shed crocodile tears about this
mandated dividend payout, but secretly
they're celebrating. This is great. No
young growth company's ever going to
make it through. Dividend
policy. Not everybody's going to be on
the same page because there'll be
winners and losers when you mandate
dividend policy. I think in general
mandating dividend policy is a bad idea
either in terms of setting a fixed
percentage as dividends or setting a
fixed percentage being reinvested. But
it keeps bubbling up to the surface. Bad
bad ideas. never seemed to go
away. Take a third case and this was one
of those cases where I struggled with
the numbers saying I must have screwed
up
someone the early 90s British I I used
to do a two-day corporate finance class
for British Petroleum. So, it's the most
unusual class I've ever done because the
there were about 20 people in the class
and they were all engineers pulled off.
You know, the company wanted them to
move up the ranks. They brought them in
say can you teach them all the corporate
finance they need to know in a couple of
days. And you know what? By day one,
they they kind of got it. I mean, they
said, "This is corporate finance. This
is what I was afraid of all this time."
And the company I used because I thought
they would relate best to was BP. So we
went through cost of capital basis
hurdle rates and capital structure. And
then I got to dividend policy on British
Petroleum. And I computed the free cash
flow equity. And the free cash flow
equity I got was 571 million on average
between 1983 and '92. And then I
computed the free cash flow
equity. It's about 1.6 billion or 1.5
billion on average over that same
period. Every year BP is returning a
billion dollars more in cash than it is
available. So first I check the
leverage. Maybe it's underleveled. No,
it was actually one of the most
overlevered oil companies in the world
by the time you got to the end because
they were funding this extra billion by
going to the bank every year and
borrowing an extra billion
dollars. This is a dividend problem made
in hell. And everybody in BP knew there
was a dividend problem, including the
janitor. You know why? Because he
wouldn't get a new broom or a new vacuum
because every dollar BP had went to
paying dividends. Across the world, they
constrained themselves because they're
paying such a big
dividend. Question you always face
whenever you look at numbers like this
is why didn't somebody do something?
This is a 10-year period, right? It's
right there. Everybody can see it's
there. Why didn't they do something
about it
earlier? Let's play it out. It's
1987. The top management at BP gathered
together. V Count so and so Lord so and
so you know you know it's British
company at that time you know royalty
I'm sure was well represented. Everybody
went to Oxford and
Cambridge. One of them banks at oh boy
we have a dividend problem. I'm trying
to act like
a Oxbridge, but I don't get it right.
And everybody says, "I I I need to do
something about the dividend problem." I
I
I cut dividends. I I I And then somebody
asked a question. Who's going to tell
the
shareholders? Say, "What's wrong with
telling the shareholders? They know we
have a dividend problem as well."
Remember what I said about shareholders?
You get the shareholders you deserve,
right? You pay no dividends. Who buys
your shares? People who don't like
dividends. You pay big dividends. Who
buys your shares? People who like big
dividends. You pay enormous dividends.
Who buys your shares? Dividend
addicts. They're addicted to dividends.
You have a room full of dividend
addicts. What are you going to tell
them? I'm going to cut dividends. It's
like getting a group of cocaine addicts
in a room. I'm going to cut your cocaine
from to onetenth of what you usually
get. You're not going to be celebrated
for doing the right thing. You're not
going to leave that room
alive. So the I I I very quickly says
not me, not me. I'm going to have
laryngitis 3 months from now. I won't be
there. And then finally somebody in the
meeting says maybe something good will
happen. Which are oil companies? What?
Maybe something will happen in the
Middle East. Oil prices will jump $20.
there our dividend problem will go away.
They put it off till 88. Same process
plays. I'll put it off till 89. Finally,
I mean, we all agree this there's a
dividend problem. Finally, 1992, BP cut
dividends. You're saying somebody had
the courage to do the right thing,
right? You know why they had to cut
dividends? Where did they get the
billion every year? They went to the
bank to borrow the money. And finally
92, they were already the most
overlevered oil company. Bank said,
"Nope, we're not lending you a billion.
So there's the news story on the day
they cut dividends. BP shares
plummet after dividend is
slashed. You did the right thing. Right?
I'll finish the story. About 6 months
later BP stock had come back to where it
was and a year later BP was a much
healthier much better company for
cutting dividends. But what was
happening in the immediate aftermath of
your cutting dividends? Those people,
those dividend addicts in your room are
selling their shares and there's a
transition period. Cutting dividends is
never going to be
painless. It's going to And that's why
if you have a dividend problem, it's
better to take care of the problem early
rather than let it fester. Because you
let it fester, you got the BP problem.
Cuz when they sold and they left the
room along the way, they actually
panicked and took half the management
with them. Half the management lost
their jobs and they deserved
to because this was a problem that
everybody knew was a problem. And I
would argue there are lots of companies
with big dividend payouts out there
where you have to look and say
somebody's got to have the courage to
make the change when you control the
spin because if it's thrust upon you
because you can't pay dividends then the
market reaction is going to be far
worse. So, if you have one of those
companies and you have a big dividend
difference to explain away, they're
paying out more than they can afford to,
first look at the leverage. Make sure
it's not under 11. But if it's not
underleveled,
then the advice you should give them is
look, do something about this now when
you still control how the process plays
out. So, if you get a chance, I would
like you to do the dividend section this
week. You really don't have much choice,
right? you like a week and a half. So,
it's not like I'll do 3 weeks from now.
Do it as soon as you can. It's not as
involved as the earlier sections. So, if
you haven't even started the process,
for God's sakes, get started. But I will
keep nagging you over the ne over the
weekend and I will see you next week.